tu es nada a merry journaliste au
quotidien l'orient le jour
bonjour madame mary merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
après la crise économique et les
manifestations régulières donc depuis la
mi octobre
le pays est à l'arrêt quelle est la
situation au moment où on se parle au
liban alors aujourd'hui tout est fermé
on fait du télétravail
pas de circulation l'aéroport est fermé
depuis mercredi soir à minuit
les écoles sont fermées depuis un peu
plus de temps depuis le 29 février
les écoles sont fermées alors voilà on
est on est confiné chez soi vous êtes
confiné chez vous alors que ces derniers
temps les libanais étaient beaucoup plus
souvent dans la rue pour protester
contre la classe dirigeante contre la
vie chère
de fait de passer 2
de tous à rien j'ai envie de dire dans
l'état d'esprit des libanais quelle est
la conséquence pour le moment on est
actif sur les réseaux sociaux
alors les entre guillemets de
manifestation c'est pas des
manifestations mais on continue à
s'exprimer sur les réseaux sociaux
et on attend le la fin du film en pour
redescendre dans la rue ça c'est sûr est
ce que le liban a les moyens de faire
face à cette pandémie
sur le plan économique au delà on a eu
des soucis parce que comme vous le savez
déjà la cause juste soulèvement
populaire était essentiellement la crise
économique du pays
mais sur le plan médical nous avons un
très bon nous avons de très bons
médecins nous avons nous avons les
moyens médicalement disons de faire face
à l'épidémie
malgré la crise économique parce que là
il y à des donations qui sont en train
d'être fait pour le pour le système pour
les hôpitaux gouvernementaux pour parler
comment dire pour les doter de cellules
pour pour corona nous avons déjà un
grand hôpital à beyrouth même l'hôpital
la fe à lille et qui à l'hôpital
universitaire les gouvernements terre en
même temps qu'au contraire le mental
excusez moi en même temps et je suis le
début de l'épidémie
et est-ce que c'est suffisant pour faire
face à cette épidémie
justement non il y a deux autres
hôpitaux privés avaient route même
qu'ils ont déjà commencé à recevoir des
patients et il y à 12 hôpitaux qui sont
sont en train d'être aménagés dans les
régions comme ça on pourra couvrir
l'ensemble dû payer pour les tests du co
lead pour du coronavirus on est en train
de le faire on a commencé à le faire à
l'hôpital il y ait là il y à quatre
laboratoires privés qu'ils commencent à
l'effectuer
comment manager la population libanaise
à au confinement
oui au confinement
ces mesures qui sont pris au fait que la
terre entière le monde est touché et le
liban forcément pas épargné exact
exactement
alors il est respecté dans la majorité
des régions où jusqu'à 90% je veux dire
on est en train de se réinventer alors
il ya les les cours qui sont dispensés à
distance il y aller les ont fait du
télétravail essentiellement même nous
les journalistes on est hors ligne et
nos déplacements on travaille plus par
téléphone et par avis à internet
alors question de se réinventer alors il
ya certains salle de gym comcom comme
tout est fermé qui sont en train
d'organiser des cours light de sport sur
sur leur site
alors les messes certaines paroisses
sont en train de le diffuser en direct
les matchs du dimanche il y à un jeune
cyr palestinien qui a fait une soirée dj
live aussi sur les réseaux sociaux et
prix de 3000 personnes l'ont écoutée
il ya même des délibérés pour déporter
boissons alcoolisées on sait rien on
occupe on s'occupe
merci à madame airs et d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste au quotidien l'orient le
jour vous étiez en direct de beyrouth